hi
i'm rifik i'm a media artist i use data
as a pigment and paint with a thinking
brush that is
assisted by artificial intelligence
using architectural spaces as canvases i
collaborate with machines
to make buildings dream and hallucinate
you may be wondering what does all this
mean so
let me please take you into my work and
my world
i witnessed the power of imagination
when i was eight years old as a child
growing up in istanbul one day my mom
brought home
a video cassette of the science fiction
movie blade runner
i clearly remember being mesmerized
by the stunning architectural vision of
the future of
los angeles a place i've never seen
before
that vision became a kind of a staple
of my daydreams when i arrived in la in
2012
for a graduate program in design media
arts i rented a car
and drove downtown to see that wonderful
world of the near future
i remember a specific line that kept
playing over and over in my head
the scene when the android raquel
realizes that
her memories are actually not hers and
when decker tells her
they are someone else's memories since
that moment
one of my inspirations has been this
question
what can a mission do with someone
else's
memories or to say that in another way
what does it mean to be an ai in the
21st century
any android or ai mission is only
intelligent
as long as we collaborate with it it can
construct things
that human intelligence intends to
produce
but does not have the capacity to do so
think about your activities in social
networks for example
they get smarter the more you interact
with them
if machines can learn or process
memories can they also dream hallucinate
involuntarily remember or
make connections between multiple
people's dreams
does being an ai in the 21st century
simply mean not forgetting anything
and if so isn't it the most
revolutionary thing
that we have experienced in our
centuries-long
efforts to capture history across media
in other words how far have we come
since ridley scott's blade runner
so i established my studio in 2014
and invited architects computer and data
scientists neuroscientists musicians
and even storytellers to join me in
realizing my dreams
can data become a pigment this was the
very first question
we asked when starting our journey to
embed media arts
into architecture to collide virtual and
physical worlds
so we began to imagine what i would call
the poetics of data one of our first
projects
virtual depictions was a public data
sculpture piece
commissioned by the city of san
francisco the work
invites the audience to be part of a
spectacular aesthetic experience
in a living urban space by depicting
affiliate network of
connections of the city itself it also
stands as a
reminder of how invisible data from our
everyday lives
like the twitter feeds that are
represented here
can be made visible and transformed into
sensory knowledge that can be
experienced collectively
in fact data can only become knowledge
when it's experienced and both this
knowledge and experience
can take many forms when exploring such
connections
through the west potential of machine
intelligence
we also pondered the connection between
human senses and the machine's capacity
for
simulating nature these inquiries began
while working on wind data paintings
they took the shape of visualized plants
based on hidden datasets that we
collected from
wind sensors we then use generative
algorithms
to transform wind speed gust
and direction into an ethereal data
pigment
the result was a meditative yet
speculative experience
this kinetic data sculpture titled
phosphorus was a similar attempt
to question our capacity to re-imagine
natural occurrences using
high-frequency radar collections of the
marmara sea
we collected sea surface data and
projected its dynamic movement
with mission intelligence we create the
sense of immersion
in a calm yet constantly changing
synthetic
sea view seeing with the brain
is often called imagination and for me
imagining architecture goes beyond just
glass
metal or concrete instead experimenting
with the furthermost possibilities
of immersion and ways of augmenting our
perception in build environments
research in artificial intelligence is
growing every day
leaving us with the feeling of being
plugged into a system
that is bigger and more knowledgeable
than ourselves in 2017
we discovered an open source library of
cultural documents in istanbul
and began working on archive dreaming
one of the first ai driven public
installation
in the world nai exploring approximately
1.7 million documents that span 270
years
one of our inspirations during this
process was a short story called
the library of babel by the argentine
writer
jorge luis borges in the story the
author conceives
a universe in the form of a vast library
containing all possible 410 page books
of a certain format and character set
through this inspiring image
we imagined a way to physically explore
the vast archives
of knowledge in the age of mission
intelligence
the resulting work as you can see was a
user-driven
immersive space archive dreaming
profoundly transformed
the experience of a library in the age
of
machine intelligence machine
hallucination
is an exploration of time and space
experienced through
new york city's public photographic
archives
for this one-of-a-kind immersive project
we deployed machine learning algorithms
to find and process over 100 million
photographs
of the city we designed an innovative
narrative system
to use artificial intelligence to
predict
or to hallucinate new images allowing
the viewer to step into a dreamlike
fusion
of past and future new york
as our projects delve deeper into
remembering
and transmitting knowledge we thought
more about how memories were not static
recollections
but ever-changing interpretations of
past events
we pondered how machines could simulate
unconscious and subconscious events such
as
dreaming remembering and hallucinating
thus we created melting memories to
visualize
the moment of remembering the
inspiration
came from a tragic event when i found
out that my uncle was diagnosed with
alzheimer's
at that time all i could think about was
to find a way to celebrate how and and
what we remember
when we are still able to do so i began
to think of
memories not as disappearing but as
melting
or changing shape with the help of
mission intelligence
we work with the scientists at the neuro
escape laboratory
at the university of california who
showed us
how to understand brain signals a's
memories are made
although my own uncle was losing the
ability to process
memories the artwork generated by
eeg data explored the materiality of
remembering
and stood as a tribute to what my uncle
had lost
almost nothing about contemporarily
matched my childhood expectation of the
city
with the exception of one amazing
building the walt disney
concert hall designed by frank gehry one
of my all-time heroes
in 2018 i had a call from elle
philharmonic
who was looking for an installation to
help mark the celebrated symphony's
100 year anniversary for this we decided
to ask
the question can a building learn
can it dream to answer this question we
decided to collect everything
recorded in the archives of the la field
and wch
to be precise 77 terabyte of digitally
archived memories
by using machine intelligence the entire
archive
going back 100 years became projections
on the building skin 42 projectors
to achieve this futuristic public
experience in the heart of los
angeles getting one step closer to the
la of
blade runner if ever a building could
dream
it was in this moment
now i am inviting you to one last
journey
into the mind of a machine right now
we are fully immersed in the data
universe of
every single created ted talk from the
past 30 years
that means this data set includes 7705
talks
from the 10th stage those talks have
been translated into
7.4 million seconds and each second is
represented here
in this data universe every image that
you are seeing in here
represents unique moments from those
talks
by using machine intelligence we process
a total of 487 000 sentences
into 332 unique clusters of topics like
nature
global emissions extinction race issues
competition trust emotions water
and refugees these clusters are then
connected to each other
by an algorithm and generated 113
million line segments which reveal new
conceptual
relationships wouldn't it be amazing to
be able to remember
all the questions that have ever been
asked on the stage
here i am inside the mind of countless
great thinkers
as well as a machine interacting with
various feelings
attributed to learning remembering
questioning and imagining all at the
same time
expanding the power of the mind
for me being right here is indeed
what it means to be an ai in a 21st
century
it is in our hands humans to train this
mind
to learn and remember what we can only
dream of thank you